we're really excited periodic videos has
won a prize
we've won prizes before but this one's a
bit different it's not a trophy not
money not a certificate but it's still
quite exciting
the prize is from this magazine science
one of the leading journals of science
in the world and we have one so called
Spore award spore is an acronym so it
stands for science the magazine prize
for online resources for education and
this is a prize that rewards what they
consider to be excellent examples of
education on the web
we haven't actually won anything except
the opportunity to write an essay for
the journal and we that's Brady and I
have written an essay about the periodic
table of videos about our website
sharing what we believe is our
enthusiasm and most importantly the
enthusiasm of you our viewers it's a
prize because it's very difficult to get
articles accepted in science it's the
real pinnacle for scientists it
publishes articles for the whole range
of science so if you're chemists it's
already difficult because only a small
proportion of the articles are about
chemistry and then nearly all the
chemists in the world are trying to get
their work their things into science and
so we're really lucky to have had this
opportunity and we hope that you'll
enjoy reading the article you can
download it and as always keep on
letting us know what you think about the
website because we want to make it
better and better well we began the
essay by me writing a first version
while sitting on the train it's good
place to write not much distraction
nobody to interrupt me no internet and
then Brady and I worked on this
manuscript backwards and forwards trying
to explain how we started periodic
videos what we were trying to do
what the role was of our different
colleagues people like Pete license who
lets off the explosions and also to try
and draw some idea about how successful
we being we've got a nice periodic table
that's Andrew where we have each of the
elements colored according to the number
of people that have watched it then also
we've been able to incorporate a few of
the comments from our various viewers
there we will read all the comments that
you put and very often they give us
ideas of other videos to make